lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
evaluar la integral definida de 0 a pi
de x coseno de x de x como siempre pausa
en el vídeo y traten de evaluar esto por
su cuenta a primera vista no es obvio
cómo podemos obtener directamente la
anti derivada de esto y evaluar la envy
y a esto restarle el valor evaluado en 0
por lo que es probable que tengamos que
usar una técnica un poco más sofisticada
y en general cuando vemos un producto de
funciones aquí y si a una de esas
funciones se le puede calcular
directamente la anti derivada sin hacer
la más complicada como coseno de x o
como con otras de las funciones como x
con la que al calcular su derivada se
vuelve más sencilla en este caso se
vuelve 1 si es así tenemos un buen
indicador de que podemos usar la
integración por partes recordemos cómo
es esta técnica de integración por
partes vamos a escribirlo aquí y lo
ponemos como una integral indefinida
aunque aquí en nuestro problema vamos a
obtener la integral indefinida para
después de evaluarla
y en cero si tengo fx multiplicada por g
prima de x de x esto va a ser igual a en
vídeos anteriores de mostramos esto y
vimos que viene directamente de la regla
de producto del cálculo diferencial esto
va a ser igual a fx por gd x menos y
ahora intercambiamos esto la integral de
f prima de x por gx de x como ya dije
queremos encontrar una f x cuya derivada
sea más sencilla y queremos encontrar
una prima de x cuya anti derivada no sea
más complicada ya que si la f x se hace
más sencilla al calcular su derivada y g
prima de x no se complica más cuando
calculamos su anti derivada entonces
quizás sea más fácil encontrar la anti
derivada de esta expresión hagamos esto
aquí entre x y coseno de x cual tiene la
derivada más sencilla la derivada de x
es igual a 1 así que es bastante
sencilla por lo que será mi f x
escribimos por acá fx es igual a x
efe prima de x es igual a 1 ahora cuál
será nuestra prima de x la anti derivada
de coseno de x no se vuelve más
complicada pues la anti derivada de
coseno de x seno de x así que haremos de
esto no está g prima de x lo escribimos
g prima de x es coseno de x y g b x es
la anti derivada de q seno de x que es
seno de x otra forma de verlo es que la
derivada de seno de x es cosa de x
podríamos agregar la constante c pero
recuerden que esta es una integral
definida y al ser evaluada las
constantes se van a cancelar ahora
apliquemos la integración por partes en
este caso todo esto va a ser igual a lo
escribimos aquí abajo
efe de x por gx fx es x
v x es seno de x por lo que nos da x x x
menos la integral de f prima de x que es
uno por gx que el seno de x
recuerden que esta es una integral
definida por lo que ahora tenemos que
evaluar todo esto en pie en cero y luego
calcular su diferencia
cuál es la integral indefinida de seno
de x de x o mejor dicho la anti derivada
de seno de x sabemos que la derivada de
seno es menos seno y para lo que
queremos podemos poner el signo negativo
dentro de la integral así que esto nos
quedaría más la integral indefinida de
menos seno de x y ahora si queda claro
que la anti derivada de esto es coseno
de x por último nos queda evaluar esto
en los límites evaluamos primero con pi
por lo que esto es igual a pi por
senodep y más coseno de pi menos el
valor de esto en 0 - 0 por seno de 0 +
coseno de 0 seno de pi es 0 por lo que
se cancela coseno de pi es menos 1 esto
es 0 y coseno de 0 es 1 por lo que
tenemos menos uno menos uno lo que nos
da menos dos y con esto terminamos
la integración por partes pudimos
evaluar esta integral definida